one thing one thing I did want to talk
about I guess I didn't think we'd get to
talk about this on trash days because I
didn't think we'd have a timely episode
it's already like a little bit old news
because it's like two weeks old now
um just seeing the whole [__]
submarine I knew you're gonna bring this
I mean I had a feeling in my balls I
mean I mean I mean it was just
weird seeing that whole event just play
out because like betting if they're like
betting money if they're alive I've
never like yeah because I've never felt
that I feel like so post-apocalyptic
yeah yeah yeah I've never felt more in a
dystopian [__] society yeah than just
seeing that event play outs like in like
real life yeah in real time because it
wasn't the event itself what I find
interesting is that it just like
captured the Public's imagination
there's just the way that you want to
briefly I know everyone knows this but
just so that this episode in like five
years someone watches it understands
what the [__] you're doing yeah so about
two weeks ago uh I believe there was a
submarine company where a bunch of uh
very well-off people uh and some of
their family members uh got into a
submarine to explore the Titanic and
before I keep the irony yes uh and uh
for a few days the sub was just
completely like lost contact nobody knew
what happened to the sub but from the
from that piece of information everyone
garnered that there was a certain amount
of air left in the sub that they could
be alive in so there was like this hope
that while the rescue mission was like
going ahead that the sub could still be
found uh later turned out that there was
a you know uh depressurization and the
they basically just died instantly yeah
collapsed in on itself collapsed in on
itself that's what found out but it was
in the time period leading up to the
wreckage being found that I find [__]
fascinating you know because there were
so many there were so many different
approaches and so many different
reactions to this thing that was
happening it was weird seeing an event
being like
this I kind of event like this being
memed before we find out like the the
fates of like everyone on boards uh but
I think it just proves that in some
level everyone's [__] terrified of
the ocean in some way with shape or form
it's a Scary Place bro yeah it's [__]
scary [__] terrifying yeah it was
weird watching uh uh I guess it was like
oh they're rich so we get to we they
should die it was pretty weird a lot of
people who are kind of are interested in
general there we give some people our
anonymity and they're like the worst
human beings on the earth yeah it's very
hard because you compare it to like
other situations that are I guess not as
similar but like when there's like some
people are trapped in a mine and they're
trying to cut them out and it's like I
don't know if it's just because like
this hasn't happened for like when was
the last time something like this
happened I think the last one that I can
think about where someone got trapped
and everyone was waiting to hear what
happened was like the tie yeah the Thai
cave which is also [__] wild as well
yeah yeah I mean like the whole online
stuff was weird but like I don't like I
don't recall anything online at least at
that period which is like people were
like memeing it or making fun like
betting money on it yeah like it was
weird like yeah oh no I feel like I feel
like I feel like something like the Thai
cave rescue that's it like the
groundwork I mean you still haven't you
thought that was kids so it's a little
different but those kids what about rich
kids though huh
all I remember is like I remember seeing
I'm having this conversation where we
had we like me and I might watch like a
documentary on the Thai cave the the
Thai cave rescue which is uh if you
don't know it's [__] crazy that story
insane yeah if we were speaking about
this the other week and you just see the
like the uh like the image of just how
far deep dude these school kids had
found themselves
like I knew it was deep but I was like
holy [__] I'm just like how the [__] do
you find yourself in this position it's
like so so if you don't know like a
bunch of like Thai school kids uh yeah
like look how [__] deep they were
yeah found themselves
three thousand meters okay see from the
entrance see the thing the thing like 3
000 meters that's like to me that's like
a number you know but seeing like the
graphic of just showing how far they
walked in from the entrance uh it just
just [__] blew my mind because I'm
like this this ain't like a wrong turn
YouTube right here like there was never
a moment during that 3 000 kilometer
hike where you're like maybe
I can't remember exactly what it was but
I think it was just like the cave had
changed because of the rain it started
raining and then they realized they
couldn't turn back off the report
because I pulled in right yeah but I'm
just like why were you that deep in
before you realized you couldn't turn
back to beginning yeah that was that was
what I was thinking uh and then they
were just like so [__] deep in and
then uh you know it was it was actually
like a pretty amazing story where you
know you had the right people at the
right time just some [__] boys
having to be there he's like yeah I'm
like one of the best cave divers in the
world yeah yeah Elon Musk called someone
a pedophile and then the kids got rescue
I love her he was like oh build a sub to
save them the guy was like that doesn't
make any sense and he's like well you're
a pedo he's like whoa what the [__] what
the [__] and then you know you have you
have events like that leading on to like
this Titanic event where it just feels
like all of the limiters just got like
[__] release well I mean I think it's
it's reflective of the online sphere and
where it's at right now where people are
just [__] unhappy and people are just
not feeling great the thing is I don't
think it was like this time because most
of the time it was like limited to
online but sometimes this one was just
like everyone you taught you'd like
you'd open up like a news broadcast and
there would literally be news broadcasts
with like a countdown of like how much
oxygen that sub has left and I'm like
what the [__] is this a game show like
like
I guess like in the news thing that's
like the hook right that's the story
yeah yeah check back in again come check
back in again it's like all they've got
like twice
maybe they didn't have the graphics and
the fancy editing yeah they had this
with the caves and the the thing they
were like they you know with the Thai
cave I think they had like a few days of
auction they were counting that down
right because it's just like people want
to know what yeah what's the what's the
well the hook a bit for like the news
things
doing the rescue it's like this is
legitimately just a time frame that we
have and for some people that becomes
very morbid and for others it's uh it's
very helpful it's weird it's yeah it's I
mean it yeah definitely showed a side of
the internet which was uh very bizarre
yes yeah it was to me it was like very
bizarre some people had like a very oh
you shouldn't be acting this way or if
you some people shouldn't be competing
this way I feel like in a lot of ways
memes are just how this generation has
like yeah with the kind of like the
hands they've been dealt so you know I
had like my own personal reaction to it
and it was you but I find it more
interesting just just to see like the
entire range of coverage and reaction
you saw from like under the sun because
it almost after a point it almost it
almost was like self-serving there was
this event and then those people
reacting to the event and then there's
people reacting to people reacting to
the event and people reacted to people
reacting to people reacting time I blew
up so much yeah yeah exactly and
everyone was talking about yeah and then
at the end of the day uh there was more
conversation about people were talking
about the event then it felt like the
event itself yeah yeah and it yeah it
was it was such a weird kind of like
news cycle to see if like unfold right
before my eyes but I guess that's kind
of the way kind of the way like the
modern
landscape has coped with like big events
yeah yeah I mean the pandemic was the
exact same thing right like just think
of the amount of [__] sometimes
hilarious sometimes horribly offensive
memes that came out of that you know so
it's like I just think that's just how
it's going to be I can't believe I'm
still in awe that some because it was
250 000 a ticket yeah there's a
billionaire
saw this sub paid the 250k was getting
in and he was like this is fine I saw
the sub I was like holy [__] yeah
construction yeah you could build the
sub a much more comfortable version of
this yeah what are you doing uh and the
fact that he brought his son along was
so [__] tragic yeah and then like the
one thing that was super interesting
about this was just learning more about
the whole submarines and that whole kind
of what like that industry or Market
whatever looks like because yeah people
are like yeah these dudes are kind of
wild they just kind of made their own
sub and said it was good they didn't
check with any regulatory uh regulatory
body well they said they said that some
of the parts were like engineered by
like NASA people and [__] like that and
I was just like I mean yeah they have
this some engineering [__] in my desk
yeah I mean sure but that's not an
excuse you know or that's not a reason
to be like yeah this this is operational
this is fine yeah because they like
mixed like uh carbon fiber and titanium
which is like a big No-No yeah
because I don't work well together and I
think this this other other stuff that
doesn't make sense we definitely went
down the submarine engineering I did I
loved it it's super interesting because
it was basically just this guy who had
made this sub was like literally his
entire pitch was trust me yeah yeah I
know what I'm doing yeah yeah and yeah
it worked for however many it worked but
it was like okay well I mean that seems
more like a miracle that it worked and
that it didn't explode before but the
fact that the guy was so confident in
this that he was the one operating in
there is wild to me yeah yeah
um but you know I think that's the only
the only thing about the the thing that
I mean it'd be super [__] if he had
made this job and was like yeah you go
in it yeah and then he won yeah then he
he wasn't not saying that he the dude
had to die or anything like that but
like the fact that he was willing to be
like I am willing to say that you just
Mr burnsing on the shore yeah yeah it's
like no refunds
but it's weird I just can't believe that
anyone would get in this hub that's
actually insane you'd have to pay me
250k to be in in that sub for eight
hours yeah let alone in there in the
[__] water and the fact that Mr Beast
got an offer as well to get in on that
[__] that's wild yeah yeah and that was
funny that whole drama yeah because he
sent it to himself